so tell us your name and what you do at
GQ besides be handsome what's the
difference in the reactions you've
gotten since you grew your hair long and
since you started bunny I feel like
there's a general good reaction to the
man bun I think it's definitely having a
moment I don't like when you have like
the stray hairs on the bottom and the
back so I'll make sure that you get a
hand sweep for that and then I kind of
try and figure out the degree of manbo
you don't want it to be too high or too
low so you know you want to find like a
good medium for for your head like all
right you pull too tight I think you
created some little bumps and yeah you
don't want those you need a mid wave
tension definitely there's all news to
me I'm I'm enjoying this make sure you
grab as much as you can wrap it twice
and then on the third time you kind of
do the swoop with the extra tail a
problem I find is when I wash it it's
really really frizzy yeah totally so I
use this v76 bun it's just a styling
famous medium hold takes away some of
that frizz so I'll probably wash my hair
twice a week and the dry shampoos for
maybe if I miss a wash it just gives it
more volume and takes away some of that
like greasy shine breaks up the oil in
your hair so it does feel a lot better
it feels a lot helped right during the
day and even after you put it in they
always wear the rubber bands I try and
have one in the hair and then one on
hand in case that breaks Jase I'm
learning about the you know the man bun
wave of the future
there's a lot of good information yeah
thank you no thank you
all right guys that's it if you got any
style questions for GQ leave them in the
comments and we'll see you next time